once discovery had happened
and the evidence came on the table and
the drug element was involved
with the pills there was another
strategy that came into play and that
strategy was
getting a drug test because you didn't
want her to have enough
time to clean herself out and you wanted
to
ensure that the drug test was a surprise
so my lawyer
once we got to that point in the hearing
process he was very clever because
eventually
she retained an attorney as well and
she didn't have initially but once once
she retained an attorney he started
advising her that changed a lot of
things
um obviously that her attorney said get
the hell out of the house
all right and and and then that kind of
nullified
my ability to legally track her so the
gps had to be pulled off the car
but um but but you know her my lawyer's
strategy went into it since we knew
we had the documented evidence that she
was she was buying opioids and she was
getting black market pills we knew that
was happening
so my lawyer strategy is you know they
get in front of the judge
it's her lawyer and my lawyer and you
know
and so of course she's lying to her
lawyer you know she's told him a whole
bunch of lies you know i'm
you know i'm just this you know i'm a
i'm abusive person you know i'm mentally
abusive and
you know i'm oh i'm a narcissist and
you're you know toxically masculine blah
blah blah yeah
yeah all that all that good stuff but so
they got into the hearing process and
my lawyers you know they the judge says
okay who wants what what's the
proposition before we go forward
and you know her my lawyers let her
laurie go first and he told the judge
you know i want
half you know half retirement i want
half i want i want alimony i want
child support i want full custody blah
blah blah i mean he went for the rope
on it and uh my lawyer just plain and
simple turned to him and a judge and
said you know what
i will give you all that you can have it
all we just got one thing
we just want both clients to go and take
a drug test immediately as soon as we
leave the judge's chambers
and because she'd been lying to her
lawyer and had not been up front with
her situation
of course without even talking to his
client he agrees to it
and says yeah that's no problem we'll do
that right away so those two
so we walked right out of the judges
chambers that point went to got a hair
follicle
and uh and your analysis and and she
failed for multiple categories in a 14
panel
so and once that happens
you get the opportunity to push the rule
and you can go for immediate emergency
order of custody for the kids
so as soon as you're talking multiple
panels like what are we talking here
like
when it everything um or what she failed
yeah like we're not talking alcohol out
here i mean we're talking like illegal
stuff right
so she fell for cocaine and and opioids
and then she also failed for um
you know like a uh i don't know what you
want to call those things like a
like a xanax sort of thing so letting
her go out partying with kevin from
sales was the best thing you could have
ever done right
100 damn 100 pay attention guys
so once once we got that it was it was
easy at that point in time because then
i got to keep the kids away from her
illegally and lawfully i got to keep her
away from me and my property
um and it was it was essentially a
downhill hill ride from that point
forward once the
once the once we got her to agree to the
drug test and she failed those panels it
was a done deal
and and the judge completely and then
you throw the private investigator to
come in
and and give testimony to what he saw it
was over
see dude like that's like that's the
beauty of the arrogance of narcissists
you know especially female narcissists
is oh yeah i'll pass a drug test yeah no
problem at all right
boom fail multiple panels beautiful
well she she actually she actually
brought up with her lawyer and said
there's no way i failed this there's no
will i failed it
and and then anything and and then and
then the lawyer said well then let's
take another test and she refused it and
then her lawyer dropped her
so then she was with that lawyer she she
did get another what lawyer who dropped
her as well
so um so so today you've got full
custody
uh justice has been served finally
thankfully you know for one guy out
there i mean you played your card
through like
like for you what what was the deciding
factor that
you feel let you win this one because
most guys don't
like for you what do you think it was
staying calm
not holding holding your your bag of
evidence don't
don't bring it to light just just keep
your mouth shut uh
play the beta male give her what she
wants let her hang herself i mean that
that was
that won this whole thing um the pi
what's that do you play poker i do play
poker yes
yeah so having a poker face helps yeah
having a poker face helps um
it when you where i had to go
emotionally and mentally was
just to keep those those flashes in my
mind for
what i read on those messages and the
evidence i'd seen
that was that you know as long as i kept
that to the forefront it allowed me to
put on the poker face a lot easier
but where men go wrong in this process
is they let they let the emotional side
take over
they don't they they don't keep quiet
and they
they circumvent the process and a lot of
males are arrogant and listen to
attorneys because you know attorneys
are going to give you this reality you
don't want to hear and you know i was
like every other guy i didn't want to
hear
you need to get a pi you need to
investigate your wife because surely
that she it can't be that bad she's just
got a little fling going on
you know but every every step of that
process
like you said and like you you mentioned
it it was stay calm
stay collected stack your chips collect
your evidence
if you do it yourself that's fine
screenshots on your phones whatever you
want to collect that's
it's a little bit more risky and and you
risk getting caught the private
investigator
way was was a way for me not to have to
take that risk and potentially get
caught
and i got a professional that knows what
they're doing
you